in early 2022 something happened that
had never happened before Somewhere over
the South China Sea American F35 stealth
Fighters had an encounter with Chinese
j20 Fighters it wasn't a fight as far as
we know they just crossed paths in March
the US Air Force acknowledged that the
encounter took place without saying when
or where the people's Liberation Army
finally followed suit a few months later
it's not that unusual for military
aircraft to meet in contested airspace
but there was something very unusual
about this encounter in particular
because the j20 was heavily based on us
stealth fighter technology that China
stole from American defense contractors
which made this random blink of an eye
encounter the culmination of China's
yearslong campaign to steal US military
technology and in this video I'm going
to tell you how they do it why they do
it and why they won't stop China often
steals American intellectual property
they try to uh Advance the interests of
a corrupt state we see that China
exponentially increasing their R&D
Investments and this effect is
multiplied by what they steal from
us Chinese military Espionage is a war
that's being fought in the massive
shadow cast by the broader us China
strategic competition to most people
it's invisible but it's actually super
important because it directly threatens
the National Security of the United
States and its Western allies while also
endangering American companies and
strengthening the Chinese government's
ability to maintain an iron grip on
power the military technology involved
in all of this is so classified it's
rare to learn the names of anyone
involved but there are a few people
whose stories help us to understand how
and why the Chinese government steals US
military technology like Sue bin from
the outside there wasn't a whole lot
about subin or Steven as he was known to
his English-speaking friends that
aroused suspicion he ran a small Chinese
aviation technology company that focused
on manufacturing aircraft cable
harnesses and together with his wife he
owned a nice house in Richmond British
Columbia just 20 mi from Canada's border
with the United States Sue was all about
business over the space of a few years
he cultivated networks of people within
the Aerospace industry most of them
probably just thought he was slightly
too eager to make a business deal but
unbeknownst to them Sue was actually
secretly orchestrating the theft of more
than half a million classified files
from some of the world's biggest defense
companies he was especially interested
in any files related to the Boeing c17
transport the c17 might have looked like
an unusual Target but it actually made a
lot of sense since it first entered
service in 1995 the c17 has become an
effective way for the US and its allies
to transport troops vehicles and
supplies to the front lines it's even
used to transport the US president's
armored limousines around the world any
military that wants to project force
over large areas needs a reliable
Transport Aircraft but American
intelligence agencies knew that the
Chinese Air Force had been struggling
for years to develop one of their own
although the c17 was made by Boeing the
company relied on dozens of smaller
contractors that supply chain provided
Sue with lots of opportunities for
infiltration his mission was clear his
method was simple after he identified
potential targets he'd pass their
details on to two Chinese military
hackers he was working with the hackers
would then send fishing emails to
individuals at the targeted companies
usually the emails were made to look
like they came from a colleague or
someone else in the industry when the
target clicked on a link in the email it
took them to a website controlled by the
pla which downloaded malware onto their
system this gave the hackers remote
access to restricted networks once they
were inside they sent lists of what they
found back to sue using his technical
knowledge he would direct the hackers on
what files to exfiltrate from there the
hackers covered their tracks by routing
the documents through servers in several
different countries eventually the files
were deposited on machines near Hong
Kong and maau at that that point Chinese
military officials picked them up in
person took them back to China and paid
sue for his work Sue and his Partners
had unfettered access to Boeing's
Network for 3 years before they were
discovered during that time they stole
more than 600,000 Files about the c17
but that wasn't all because they also
stole tens of thousands more Files about
the F22 and F35 the world's most
advanced fighter planes in the end the
hackers were partly undone by their own
bragging in 2011 one of the Chinese
officers who worked with Sue emailed the
other attaching a report detailing the
success of their operation it was
basically a confession Sue was arrested
in Canada and extradited to the United
States and in 2016 he was sentenced to
four years in prison by a court in Los
Angeles but his mission was already a
success in November of 2014 The People's
Liberation Army debuted the y20 cargo
plane it just happened to Bear a
striking resemblance to the Boeing c17
it was even a C7 parked nearby at the
air show where the y20 was first
unveiled it looked like the pla had
managed to come up with a solution after
all like I mentioned Sue bin and his
accomplice also managed to steal
information about the F35 but that
wasn't even the first time that had
happened as far back as 2007 Chinese
hackers infiltrated locked Martins
networks and stole terabytes of data
about everything from the f-35's radar
systems to its engine schematics in 2009
The Wall Street Journal reported another
Cyber attack this time targeting the
f-35's electronic systems Chinese
hackers were apparently so successful
that before being discovered they
covertly sat in on what were supposed to
be secure online press conferences and
in late 2016 a small Australian
Aerospace company that subcontracts with
the Department of Defense was hacked and
documents about the F-35 C130 Transport
Aircraft and Australian Naval vessels
were stolen the hackers didn't have to
try very hard an investigation found
that the company's internet facing
Services still had their default
passwords the Chinese government's
patience would soon pay off on Tuesday
all eyes were on the Chinese made j20
stealth fighter it's armed with
long-range missil and if it looks
familiar that's because it Bears a
striking resemblance to the F-35 and
F-22 war planes made in the United
States there's something slightly
unusual about the fact that Chinese
government hackers expended so much
energy and effort to steal information
about the F35 the F-35 might be the most
widely criticized war plane ever the F35
was born of an exceptionally dumb Air
Force PR spin it started with incredibly
High Hopes when the contract for the
Joint Strike Fighter a program created
by the US military in order to develop a
superior versatile fighter plane was
awarded to locked Martin in 2001 but the
program has been plagued by a series of
design problems delays and cost overruns
by 2017 less than two years after the
first F35 entered service the F35 was
forecast to cost 1.5 trillion over its
lifespan so it sort of raises the
question if the F-35 is so bad why did
China try so hard and force so long to
steal it well because despite all the
problems with the F35 it's still one of
the world's best fighter planes and
stealing the technology that underpinned
it allowed the Chinese government to
take a big step forward in their grand
geopolitical
strategy Sue operation was highly
successful until he got caught but that
didn't bother the people who ordered the
Operation or their bosses or their
bosses because he was ultimately just
one foot soldier in a huge Army of
Chinese hackers dedicated to stealing
the West's most sensitive Commercial and
Military Secrets over the last two
decades China has built an enormous
cyber Espionage Network one of the main
nodes of that network was a 12 story
building on 208 datong Road near
Shanghai airport it may have looked like
a regular boring office building and in
some ways it was Personnel had access to
a medical clinic and a kindergarten but
it was also the office of a secret pla
cyber warfare unit unit
61398 exists almost nowhere in Chinese
government documents you're more likely
to find references to it in US
Government documents a secret State
Department cable written in 2008
mentioned an attack by a Chinese hacking
group code named Byzantine kandor which
stole more than 50 megab of emails and a
list of Account Details from a US
government agency they were talking
about unit
61398 still the public was completely
unaware of its existence until that is
an American cyber security company
released a report which among other
things identified the unit as the one
that was behind the theft of the F35
designs for 7 years mandiant secretly
monitored the activities of unit 61398
hackers over that time the group was
responsible for at least 141 attacks
which cumulatively stole hundreds of
terabytes of data mandiant watched from
the shadows as unit 61398 hackers stole
blueprints manufacturing processes
clinical trial results pricing documents
negotiation strategies and other
proprietary information from more than a
hundred of its clients mostly in the US
more than 20 industries from defense
contractors to chemical plants mining
companies and Telecommunications
corporations were targeted and Mandan
also learned through analy ing their
techniques and tracing their IP
addresses that unit 61398 hackers were
working out of the same building that
nondescript 12-story office on datong
Road it's kind of ironic by uncovering
unit 61398 mandiant showed exactly the
kind of Ingenuity and talent that made
so many American companies Prime targets
for Chinese Espionage operations the
report made headlines across the world
and alerted everyone to the threat posed
by systematic state sponsored Chinese
Espionage in May of 2014 the Department
of Justice indicted five members of unit
61398 everyone knew there was no chance
the hackers would be extradited to face
the charges but it was still a sign that
the Obama Administration was willing to
publicly call out China over its ongoing
theft of corporate and Military Secrets
however China was about to up the ante
more than 21 million Americans had
personal information stolen from
government files in a data breach that
was six times as large as originally
disclosed the op M hack resulted in the
theft of 22 million security clearance
files on American officials military
personnel contractors and Intelligence
Officers intelligence agencies realized
what it meant the Chinese government was
assembling a massive database of almost
everyone in the American national
security Community The Fallout from the
OPM hack was huge the CIA couldn't move
some of their officers to China because
they were concerned their covers were
blown and the Obama Administration
offered millions of Americans credit
protection in case the hackers had their
credit card number numers the arrest of
the unit 61398 hackers and the OPM hack
made Chinese Espionage the biggest issue
in the US China relationship and it led
directly to what looked like an
incredible breakthrough the United
States government does not engage in
cyber economic Espionage for commercial
gain and today I can announce that our
two countries have reached a common
understanding on the way forward we've
agreed that neither the us or the
Chinese government will conduct or
knowingly support cyber enabled Seth
theft of intellectual property including
Trade Secrets or other confidential
business information for commercial
Advantage the US China cyber agreement
felt like an arms control deal for
cyberspace and on the surface it seemed
to achieve results the security firm
fire eye released a report a year after
the deal which claimed the number of
successful attacks by the Chinese
hacking groups it was tracking fell by
more than 80% soon after signing the
agreement with the United States seun
ping signed a similar deal with the
United kingdom was the Chinese
government actually about to stop its
Espionage activities spoiler alert no it
wasn't up until about 2014 the pla was
the main force behind China's Espionage
operations but the unmasking of unit
61398 and the public identification of
five of its members was a major
embarrassment it ended up being one of
the factors behind Sean Ping's decision
to reorganize the people's Liberation
Army and Purge several of its leaders as
part of the reorganization power was
centralized within the min hisory of
State security a powerful agency that
combines elements of the FBI CIA and NSA
suddenly the same organization that
monitors Chinese people at home was
given the job of stealing secrets from
China's Rivals this centralization of
Power coincided with what on paper
looked like a decline in Chinese cyber
Espionage attacks against American
companies and organizations but the
truth is that was deceptive most of the
decline actually took place before the
agreement was announced
and China kept hacking it just turned
its attention to places like Russia and
Southeast Asia and although we'll never
know for sure it probably took some time
for the reforms within the Chinese
government to play out and for the
ministry of State security to acquire
new high value cyber Espionage targets
within the United States chances are
seun ping knew all of this when he stood
next to Barack Obama in the Rose Garden
he never had any intention of stopping
Chinese Espionage operations he probably
just wanted to gain a diplomatic
advantage while buying himself some time
to increase his government's capacity to
conduct them and after years of Obama's
diplomacy Sean ping was about to deal
with a very different US president China
China China China China China China
China China One of Donald Trump's
signature policies as president was his
trade war against China he'd been
talking about unfair Trade Practices for
decades and finally he had a chance to
do something now I'm not going to argue
whether or not the trade war was a good
idea but in terms of preventing
espionage it was a failure and the truth
is it was never going to succeed because
nothing that Trump or any us leader
could have done was going to dissuade
Sean ping from the strategy he'd chosen
so far I've talked about how China
steals us Commercial and Military
technology but now it's time to zoom out
and ask a really important question why
does China steal us technology right off
the bat let's get something straight
every country conducts Espionage they
view it as an integral part of National
Security and every country knows that
other countries are conducting Espionage
on them it's a routine part of
geopolitics but there are three things
that make China's Espionage activities
different let's go through them one by
one first the purpose Sue bin explained
it perfectly in one of the emails that
was used as evidence against him the
F-22 and F35 documents he helped steal
would in his words allow China to catch
up rapidly with us levels and stand
easily on the Giants shoulders the
Chinese Communist Party led by Sean ping
is on a mission to surpass the United
States as the world's preeminent
military and economic leader and the two
go hand inand as China's military
becomes more powerful it's able to exert
more influence in the indo-pacific
coercing its Rivals and extracting more
value out of things like trade deals but
making that ambition a reality requires
making quick leaps and China's leaders
have decided that rather than doing it
the old-fashioned way like investing in
R&D the best way to catch up quickly is
by stealing us technology the j20 the
plane that had that close encounter with
the American f35s over the South China
Sea is a perfect example it's only the
third fifth generation fighter in the
World Behind the F35 and F22 the two
planes its design is based on the j20 is
designed to dominate the Skies over the
South China Sea one of the most
contested regions in the entire world
Sean ping sees it as a key part of
China's ability to project military
power in the region in the event of an
actual conflict say over Taiwan the j20
will be one of the main ways that the
Chinese military tries to deny area
access to US Naval vessels and aircraft
as China's World influence expands so is
its military beijing's goal is to
surpass the United States and although
China's leaders would prefer to do it
peacefully if there is a war they want
to level the playing field second the
scale the scale of Chinese Espionage
activities against the United States is
staggering credible estimates from 5
years ago put the annual cost at $320
billion some of them are lower but we're
still talking about tens of billions of
dollars every year and of course that's
only the ESPN that we know about there
are plenty of reasons why an
intelligence agency or defense
contractor might not disclose that
they've been hacked so the true cost of
China's Espionage activities is probably
a lot higher China has a bigger hacking
program than that of every other major
Nation combined according to Christopher
Ray the director of the FBI the agency
opens a new China related Counter
Intelligence case about every 10 hours
you might have noticed that I'm not
making much of a distinction between
military and economic Espionage there's
a reason for that neither does China
China doesn't make this distinction
either article 7 of China's national
intelligence law states that any
organization or citizen shall support
assist and cooperate with the state
intelligence work in accordance with the
law in China the line between the
government and the private sector is so
blurry that it doesn't exist many large
Chinese businesses are state-owned
Enterprises and even if they aren't the
government still controls them just look
at w way Espionage is a state policy in
China and it will remain that way as
long as the Chinese government isn't
subject to any constraints on its power
third the means the Chinese government
uses a diverse range of techniques to
conduct Espionage sometimes it
cultivates an intelligence asset like
suin using him to identify targets and
then hacking those targets another
technique involves enticing people to
covertly share knowledge with China in
2019 a texas-based scientist was
convicted after he stole trade secrets
from regarding syntactic foam an
important Naval technology used in
submarines the state-owned Enterprise
that benefited from the theft even ended
up patenting the manufacturing process
they stole and then offered the American
company a joint venture that was an
example of another famous Chinese
Espionage technique coercing American
companies to share or give up their
intellectual property in order to access
the Chinese market the techniques are
diverse and so are the Technologies we
know what technologies China is most
interested in because they've told us
the made in China 2025 strategy
announced by Sean ping a few months
before the US China cyber agreement
identifies specific Industries like
Aerospace automation artificial
intelligence and Quantum Computing where
China should gain an advantage today
almost all of China's Espionage focuses
on those
Industries like I said earlier when we
talk about Chinese state sponsored
Espionage it's rare to learn about
people's real stories but sometimes
there's a story which perfectly
encapsulates the prer issue in March of
2017 an engineer at GE Aviation received
a LinkedIn request from an official at a
university in Eastern China GE Aviation
was an ideal Target because it builds
airplane and helicopter engines for the
Pentagon and the engineer was an ideal
Target because he grew up in China like
most people who use LinkedIn he was used
to getting requests from strangers he
accepted the request without thinking
too much about it a few days later the
official invited the engineer to the
university to give a research
presentation the engineer felt honored
at the recognition before he moved to
the US for grad school he'd grown up in
a small village now he was being asked
to share knowledge about aerospace
engineering plus he'd get to see his
family and friends it was a dream
opportunity there was just one problem
the engineer knew that if he asked GE
wouldn't give him permission to go so he
didn't ask instead he clarified with the
official from the University that he'd
only discuss general research on
composite materials not anything he was
working on at GE no problem the official
said after the engineer gave the talk he
was handed an envelope with
$3500 reimbursement for travel and a
payment for the talk he went back home
to the United States and that was the
end of the story except of course it
wasn't a few months later the engineer
got a call asking him to attend a
meeting with GE security officers he was
already feeling tense earlier that day
he and his teammates had been asked to
hand over their hard drives and then
their laptops his worst fears were soon
realized the officers wanted to know
more about his trip to China where did
he visit and why the engineer said he
just went back for a College reunion and
to connect with friends and family wrong
answer the security officers told the
engineer that a couple of FBI agents
wanted to talk to him in fact they were
already in the building they entered the
room and started asking the engineer
questions about the trip he stuck to the
story he gave the security officers
finally exasperated the agents showed
him their evidence that he had visited
the University they reminded him that it
was a crime to lie to federal agents and
they asked him again what did he do in
China eventually the engineer confessed
he said he'd given a presentation about
designing airplane parts from Composite
Materials although he was careful not to
divulge any proprietary information he
had downloaded some GE training files to
help him prepare the FBI agents knew
something I'm sure you've already picked
up on his host were trying to use the
engineer to steal Trade Secrets
eventually the agents offered a deal
they wouldn't recommend charges if the
engineer agreed to participate in a
counterintelligence operation against
China the FBI had already searched the
engineers home towed his car and caught
him lying some of the GE documents he
downloaded were marked export controlled
he was in big trouble so he said yes the
FBI was especially interested in Chui a
local bureaucrat from the Jong Su
Science and Technology Association who
presented the engineer with some loose
leaf tea in Nan Jing they believed that
the association was a front for the
Chinese government and that Chu was
actually an intelligence officer they
saw an opportunity to learn more about
Chu and about China's Espionage
operations in December a month and a
half later the FBI directed the engineer
to write to chew over WeChat saying that
he'd like to visit China again over
Lunar New Year by the time Chu wrote
back to say he could make that happen
the FBI already had search warrants for
two of his email addresses they also
discovered that each of the addresses
were linked to an Apple ID and iCloud
account so they obtained more search
warrants much like how mandian had shown
just how many US companies were targeted
by Chinese Espionage this discovery was
a funny twist of fate the iPhone a
product of American technological and
business prowess was a key asset in the
fight against a rival nation's efforts
to steal technology one of the iCloud
accounts was a treasure Trove all the
proof the FBI needed was there it showed
that Chu's real name was Su Yan June and
that he worked for the ministry of State
security the FBI found his national ID
card pay stubs and even his vacation
requests but the biggest piece of
treasure was an audio recording from
2016 where Sue urged a professor at
noning University to work harder to
obtain military technology quote the
leadership asks you to get the materials
of the US F-22 fighter aircraft you
can't get it by sitting at home learning
their Target's true identity
significantly raised the stakes for the
FBI it gave them solid proof that the
theft of trade and Military Secrets was
orchestrated by Beijing the FBI wasn't
satis ified with just knowing who Shu
was they wanted to arrest him they
instructed the engineer to keep up the
correspondence Sue eventually asked for
material relating to the design of a
particular type of fan blade the
engineer sent over a GE document but it
was bait GE which was cooperating with
the FBI operation altered it so that it
didn't contain any valuable information
Sue bit he sent the engineer a list of
Technologies to collect the engineer
again appearing to comply with the
request emailed sue a copy of his laptop
directory only GE had stripped out all
of the sensitive information he then
mentioned that he'd be traveling to
France on a work trip in March of 2018 a
year after he received that first
LinkedIn request the engineer suggested
meeting somewhere away from his GE
colleagues like Belgium Sue thought he
was really getting somewhere but in
truth he was walking into a trap the FBI
thought France wouldn't arrest him but
that the belgians would in March the
engineer flew to Brussels but sue the
Chinese intelligence officer was in the
Netherlands he was frustrated by the
change of plans maybe he suspected
something was up so he proposed to
compromise meet in reram which was
closer to the Belgian border all of a
sudden the FBI needed a reason why the
engineer couldn't come to the
Netherlands if they didn't think of one
the entire operation might have fallen
apart but they came up with a good one
the engineer's boss had booked an Easter
lunch for the whole team and attendance
was mandatory he needed to be in Belgium
Sue finally agreed and sent the engineer
a photo of a coffee shop in a historic
Gallery in central Brussels the meeting
was arranged for 3:00 p.m. but it never
happened Sue went to scope the location
beforehand accompanied by a colleague as
the two men approach the coffee shop
Belgian federal police officers arrested
them the two men were carrying 7 Grand
in $100 bills money they were going to
give the engineer 6 months later Sue was
extradited to the US to face charges of
economic Espionage Sue and the engineer
had lots in common both saw academics as
their ticket out of poverty they were
both born the first people in their
families to go to college and they both
studied engineering but at a fateful
moment their lives diverged in 2003 the
same year the engineer left for the US
in a new life Sue started working for
the ministry of State security when
Sue's trial began in October of 2021 the
prosecution presented a recording of a
4-Hour long meeting between him and
several Chinese engineers in the meeting
he explains how to spot potential
recruits while targeting specific
Technologies quote for example if I am
an aircraft person then I would search
for Boeing or locked right find it at
locked Martin after I found the person I
would find out if this person is doing
something like in charge of overall
designs or avionics digging deeper they
made another Discovery starting in 2010
Sue helped run a campaign that targeted
three aerospace companies Capstone
Turbine saffron and Honeywell which
supplied components for China's first
ever domestically manufactured
commercial airliner a saffron engineer
installed malware provided by Sue onto
the laptop of one of his colleagues
Sue's defense attorney tried to argue
that he was just a pawn caught up in the
competition between two world powers it
didn't work in November of 20122 Sue was
sentenced to 16 years in prison Sue's
arrest was like capturing an enemy
combatant during war but it's an unusual
kind of war no shots are being fired no
missiles are being launched but unless
America is able to effectively counter
Chinese military Espionage the US faces
the real Prospect of fighting a future
conflict against a rival equipped with
Technology based largely on the
innovation of American companies as a
senior us defense official put it to the
New York Times during the Cold War we
were focused every day on the nuclear
command centers around Moscow today it's
fair to say that we worry as much about
the computer servers in Shanghai and the
danger is that as the US develops more
advanced weapon systems to counter
China's growing military threat China
will just try its best to steal that
technology too in August of 2023 two US
Navy sailors were arrested in Southern
California for providing military
secrets to Chinese Intelligence Officers
it was proof in case we needed it that
Sean ping will keep trying to steal US
military technology because stealing
military technology sits at the heart of
his strategy to increase China's
influence in the world and ultimately
overtake the United States Beijing has
already gained terabytes worth of
information on Advanced us weapon
systems and used that information to
build its next generation of aircraft
drones and missiles but the fight is
never over over the US and its allies
must increase their resilience against
Chinese state sponsored Espionage it
must continue to invest in research and
development both in the military and
corporate sectors it must always strive
to show the rest of the world that
democracy and openness is better than
authoritarianism and censorship to learn
how the US military needs to change in
order to defeat China just watch this
video next thanks a lot